la touraine aujourd'hui est à l'honneur
au stand au centre val de loire
des animations culinaires dégustations
c'est l'occasion de présenter les
produits de la région
[Musique]
dans les allées la commanderie du
fromage de chèvre 5 maure de touraine
assure la promotion de la op
l'appellation d'origine protégée
[Musique]
le salon de l'agriculture une vitrine
pour les producteurs et les éleveurs au
stand vga le syndicat des jeunes
agriculteurs ou propose également des
dégustations de produits locaux
c'est aussi l'endroit idéal pour
sensibiliser les parlementaires de la
région aux problématiques de leur
profession aujourd'hui on a une
accumulation de cours mondiaux très bas
d'une réforme de la carte des zones
défavorisées qui a été mal fait et en
même temps l'ouverture à l'importation
des pays d'amérique du sud de produits
qui sont aux distorsions de concurrence
dont on a besoin qu'au moins sur ce qui
les concerne directement les
parlementaires la loi sur les états
généraux l'implantation et la loi sur le
foncier
il s'implique pleinement et ils
soutiennent la démarche le salon au
passage vivement conseillé aux élus de
l'agriculture c'est un projet de société
et qui on a le temps d'en parler on a le
temps d'en discuter ou les enjeux les
jeux les rangs puisque je les touristes
allemands courageux c'est un métier très
difficile surtout dans le contexte
actuel
et voilà je viens pour les soutenir
jusqu'à la fin de l'événement les jeunes
agriculteurs récolteront des signatures
de soutien à leur cause
dans les mois à venir ils surveilleront
de près le projet de loi sur
l'alimentation